Konichiwa. Nihao.
Honolulu.
So can you in two words describe what
you're doing here today at Elon?
Ummmm
Two Words
Yeah
No those are my two words
Well to be honest with you I'm here to meet women
Uh I know a little bit about toothpaste
Hey kids!
yeah we're all children of God murder
Murder your way to freedom
Love is not the answer.
Death is.
Stop doing drugs and start killing!
These are used to control things but not the
minds of others. This is for children man. God would only hope you can
defend yourself if someone were to
violently attack you which will happen someday.
You gotta pass it on you got to
pass it on to get it on. That always stuck with me.
I get off. For sure.
there's so many Puerto Ricans nowadays
that you're like hey hey go back to
Puerto Rico
hey Puerto Ricans I'm walking here!
Is this for the kids?
Wait can you cut that out?
Healthcare for all.
Nah
Just me
you know what your nickname is?
What.
I wish I had a good one to say but I don't
The flying jerk
Look at that beautiful picture Reilly
drew of himself.
No I didn't draw that.
That looks nothing like me
Really? my lips
Yeah God fucked Mary. To have Jesus.
God was the first like
incest porn.
I just keep forgetting that I am bla-
I am black.
You can turn porn on just can't turn it off
This is where I get all my chicks dude.
Here we are
Yeah here's the African art
You like it rough boy?
Ummm
Nah